[Music]
i
am so excited today because olivia scott
welch formerly known as olivia welch is
back on my
show i am so excited to talk to her she
stars as sam
and hannah in the fear street trilogy
that is fully out now
we're gonna be talking spoilers so if
you haven't watched all the films come
back after
olivia how you doing today good how are
you
good yeah you know last time i talked to
you we had ray nicholson with us so it's
the first time
we're doing one-on-one i'm honored to be
with you it's my birthday i'm wearing a
very
birthday card happy birthday thank you
so
it's a birthday treat to talk to you and
um so
this is what's awesome because sam
really takes you know
front and center hero a lot in 1616 six
but you're
seeing half of it as hannah so was it
more challenging
playing hannah than sam especially doing
that accent
oh my gosh the accents were crazy um
but yeah it felt weirdly like a good
kind of natural transition because we
filmed 94
first and then we filmed 66 second
and so we had kind of like established
sam and dina and keana and i had kind of
like we had really bonded by that point
and were like very felt
comfortable and like safe acting with
each other
and then it was fun at that and we had
been doing such like
crazy where it's like i drown and like
we're running through a hospital and
like we have to murder everybody you
know what i mean so
when we got to 66 and we're filming
those scenes at the beginning
we were like what a nice treat to like
be
just smiling at each other just doing
some flirting in this field you know
so it was fun to like make sam and then
get her so like messed up and possessed
and
go through such a hard time and
absolutely get hit in the head over and
over
and then get to do hannah and then
everyone just kind of felt like so
relieved and it was fun because then it
was like we had all this pent up like
goofy energy that we were like excited
to get out
but the accents were crazy but yeah no
coach for a while which was very helpful
oh no it's good and
you did a great job with it and i want
to bring up what you just mentioned
about
you having this chemistry with kiana and
comfortability which you totally do did
you guys have to do like a chemistry
read
when you were auditioning for the part
and how do you get that comfortable with
the scene partner like building that
trust
yeah we did do a chemistry read we did a
chemistry in new york
and it was like six hours long and
chianic because they like
mixed it they were like three sams and
three genus and they matched us all
together
and then kiana and i specifically did
like scenes together for like two hours
and we like left this room and we were
like
wow well we were in there for a long
time and then we were like
do you think that we booked this movie
like because
we were in there for a long time doing
all sorts of things together
and so we felt pretty i that was nice
because it was like that when we got to
set we had already
acted together for literally two and a
half hours so
we felt already comfortable but i think
lee our director is like incredible at
um finding people and casting people and
everyone has like incredible energy in
the movies and like
are literally some of the best people
i've ever met in my entire life
and so it was very easy with hiana
because she's just an incredible person
and so it was like
there there wasn't anything where i was
like i don't know about this girl like
she
is so trustworthy and loyal as is and
she's just a wonderful actor and
yeah like we sat down and we like mapped
out our relationship and
and talked about all the stuff that you
don't see in the movie to just like
build that foundation and
before we even started filming so like
that was already there and then we just
we're together every day for
months and like it's it's a thing where
it's like you can't not
just build a trust with somebody as an
actor and a person when you're
together that often yeah and that's a
tribute to all the hard work you're both
putting in
and it shows it's getting reward because
one of the biggest things i've seen on
social media about these films is people
being in love with this relationship of
dina and sam
now what stood out to you about this
trilogy how it handled gay
representation compared to like other
films in the past like what was
really the sticking point for you i
think it was just the thing that it's
like
it's not even necessarily like discussed
in the movie at all which i thought was
the coolest like it's like their friends
are like yes sam and dean are together
and they're working it out and their
drama and it's crazy you know what i
mean but it's never like
treated like they're any different than
anyone else or like that anything
specific about them is like sticking out
to everyone around
them and it was just so cool because i
was like yeah that's how like straight
relationships are treated in movies you
know what i mean like you don't have to
be like
straight so you know and so you know
like
just like heteronormative things in
movies aren't discussed at all and that
was something reading the script i was
like it's not discussed at all that
they're they're just in a relationship
because they're simply two people
and their friends treat them as such you
know and that was like the coolest
because i was like this is the way to
handle this you know and it felt really
cool to like film those scenes
with everybody yeah and it's it's so
enjoyable and i think it's connecting to
so many
different types of audiences which is
just to applaud your performance
and obviously kiana's but now what was
what was the big twist
because you know when i talked to you
about saying this interview you really
want to talk about this film in
particular and what shocked me about
1666
which you didn't tell me which was the
shocker was it jumps back
to 1994. so we see it's crazy so
i i almost forgot that sam was still
possessed so
was was this really hard as an actress
to get to that level
was it exhausting because of how much
energy you're exerting doing that
and um did you have to do this in your
audition
i didn't have to do it my audition it
was definitely
exhausting because it is so much energy
because like the scenes
especially the scenes in 78 where i'm
tied to the radiator
they were just actually tying me up
like i would have to get like tied and
tied out like it wasn't like a fake you
know what i mean like where it was like
it's like a ripoff like vest you know
that like it was like fully
i was fully tied to like a radiator for
hours
and hours forgot about you or anything
no no people would come and be like
hey do you need any water and i'd be
like
yeah and keon and benji would just like
sit there with me on the ground and be
like
isn't today weird we'd be like yeah that
is weird
but um everyone was very accommodating
but yeah it just was so much energy and
um
it was like a thing where i was like i
really wanted to like commit to those
things because i was like this could
border the line of being goofy if
it's not scary you know so i really was
like i
need to commit every moment of this that
is on camera because they could use any
of it
so there was just so much and then like
yeah like when we're in the pizza shop
and i'm tied up and everyone's like
talking but i'm in the background like
convulsing like
you know like it was just so much
physical exertion and i was like covered
in bruises
all the time and like having to take so
much arnica
but um it was very like cathartic and
fun
to do those yeah no and your question it
remind me a lot of like how good we've
seen
you know different actors portray this
in like exorcism films and
thank you it's not easy to do so i think
that's awesome now
people always want to know this stuff
too like when you were auditioning were
you always going to play the part of sam
did you audition for other parts as well
in this film
i did like one audition for kate but
julia was already auditioning and i was
friends with julia already and i
remember
lee was like i was like how'd the kate
audition look
because she was i think in a uh she was
somewhere she was maybe in atlanta or
something prepping and she was like
your kate audition was good she was like
but julia auditioned and i was like give
it to julia
i was like don't even i was like throw
my tape out the window
like julia is perfect for this like it's
the best casting of all time
and um she was like yeah we're just
gonna stick to sam because julia's gonna
be kate and i was like that's amazing i
don't need to be kate
julia is kate she is yeah you you just
didn't want your head being sliced by a
bread slicer that's what it was
i was like no oh no i'm so sad
um okay so but that's the thing too
which like just bring up the red slicer
i love
so many of the kills in this trilogy it
really doesn't shy away from that rated
r
rating um but we see in this final film
all the shady side killers now really
coming here
into the court you olivia have a
personal favorite
oh this is a good question i
love
man oh i don't know steve i don't know
i really love out of not the like big
three of skull mask nightwing and ruby i
do love the milkman because i think he's
okay great and um like the little back
story they gave about him was so scary
and i was like this is real real crazy
but i don't like all the
chris nelson did our our um like special
effects inspired like was our
head of makeup and everything and he is
like a true icon like he's a legend
to cinema and so every time like there
would be days where he would be like
opening casts of masks and stuff like
that and every day i was like this is
so cool like he is just firing on all
cylinders with these
creatures because everything was so
crazy looking and his team was so
incredible and
he's like such a horror like a deep
horror fan so i feel like he nailed it
with all of them
and i simply can't decide i'm like yeah
i don't know
no i don't blame you and even bring up
the milkman i think what excites people
is that we hopefully maybe we'll see
these
characters in future projects um but
switching gears a bit
yeah i have to you know since i talked
to you from when you were
doing press for panic on prime and i'll
talk to you now you've become a bit of a
fashion icon here on instagram it's is
fashion something that is a passion to
you just as much as acting is
yeah i think definitely i remember being
like a really
young like really young like four or
five and being like
i'm gonna watch project run away with my
mom and then i'm gonna go watch twilight
done with my dad
and then we're gonna watch jaws all
together you know what i mean so it was
like
constantly right there with movies
and yeah like i just remember like
reading like my mom would buy me vogue
sometimes as a kid like when she was at
the you know like it was it was always
such a big part of my life
and also something i think is such an
intersection of movies
like costume design is always so
incredible and stuff to me so
i feel like the fac my love of fashion
my love of movies at some point when i
was like at like 12 or so
i was like i can combine these together
and
in this whole actress thing and be an
actress
fashion icon and then that became like
my goal for myself some genius
you're becoming your own brand it's
perfect oh thank you so much smart
business lady right here
but now what was also speaking of the
fashion i feel like
the whole cast of fear street has a lot
of really good fashion and there's this
great
picture you posted where the next slide
is the teletubbies
yeah okay where did that come from was
that here you who figured that out who
was the mastermind
it was literally like myself emily kiana
ryan and i
doing some press on one of the days
and we were sitting there and we got
done and lee schroeder who's like our
unit publicist at netflix she was like
come here and then she like flipped her
laptop around and it was that was my
helicopter
like where did you how did you even how
did you even
figure this out in your brain that
quickly that that's what you were
thinking of
but she was on top of it and she was
like i'm making memes for you guys over
here while y'all are doing your
interviews with things
yeah it's one of the best matching shots
i've ever seen it's incredible
we were like this is exactly what we're
wearing
this is insane and
yeah and speaking of two like you do all
these press stores i hope people
understand like when you're doing these
shows you're getting all this attention
you guys are also grinding out doing all
these interviews
and i think what's so cool about you
just from talking when you were first
breaking on the scene with panic to now
blowing up on fear street you've always
been very kind to me and a humble person
is that something you value though like
that you will keep and treasure as you
keep going up this ladder here
yeah definitely that's something where
i'm not even like i hope so because i'm
i'm making a very conscious
effort because i'm like it's so
like it's so taxing for us to do press
in like a very like fun way but it's you
know it's like exhausting you do it like
all day long days in a row and yeah it's
like everybody's literally just trying
to
talk about the movies you know what i
mean like you're as passionate about
talking about the movies as we are so
it's like why would i not extend that
grace to you you know what i mean like
it just makes common sense to me in my
brain
yeah everyone's just trying to do their
job and everyone is equally as
passionate about what they're talking
about and
it's it's pretty simple in my head i'm
like everybody's just trying to like be
work as a team and like get this product
out there
yeah for sure and i think that's cool
because like
it's good that you have that attitude
because like you come off as a leader
and having a big role in the film
i think everyone kind of radiates um so
before i let you go it'd be criminal to
the fans of these films for me not to
ask you this but
we get like almost like an mcu
mid-credits scene at the end of 1666
where these mystery hands grab this book
yes if anything you can answer do you
think we'll get more
fear street films is there a chance and
could we see this cast kind of do maybe
like a
you know american horror story anthology
kind of thing
that's truly all that i want i like
what i don't know anything about it
specifically like
you know i know that like the idea is
out there and people
are thinking about it on the production
side but i am like
down i've told them before i'm like i
will i will be
i will be the jbl curtis of this like i
love these movies so much and i love
everybody
that made them so much and i'm so proud
of them that i like i'll keep coming
back i'll write some for you guys like i
don't even care
i'll put i will keep the fear straight
franchise alive
oh no i love that and i and that's good
people want to hear that because that
gives us a chance like you said maybe
we'll see the milkman look at his whole
story yeah we want to see
and that's the thing too i'm like how
can we bring back
simon and kate like i'm trying my best
to come up with some logic to pitch
netflix and cheering of like how to get
people back because i also want them
back i don't want to film a movie
without those guys you know
100 um i have faith the creative people
figure this out
um before i let you go i have to address
the elephant in the room
i don't know if that's a mask behind you
or something but is that part of your
next fashion piece
hold on i'll show you because i'm like
what is that
so my writing partners and i made this
little movie
in the woods during class okay just to
make a movie in the woods during
quarantine and it was scary
on the party slasher and we hope someday
people will see it
but in it um everybody dies
and their needs were made holy crap
that are directly and yeah our directors
teddy padilla and he like is a a
big chris nelson follower that's a great
way to put it
but he's great at like special effects
makes up and props making and so he made
everybody's own skull
and this one has like a broken jaw and
it looks like this
but some of them were grosser than this
and some of my god
bloody and handmade so that's amazing so
you really are
true die hard horror fan that is oh yeah
definitely
um so everyone you've heard it all from
here from olivia you've watched all the
trilogy go re-watch it support these
films they're all out on netflix now
and if you haven't if you love olivia
welch watch her series panic on prime
it's
great um thank you so much for joining
me olivia
and i hope to talk to you a third time
one day i know me too